widerstand gibt es so gut wie keinen
zu den wenigen ausnahmen gehört major
langhäuser generalstabsoffizier der
heeresgruppe süd entschlossen verweigert
er die herausgabe von gefangenen die von
der ss erschossen werden sollen ohne
gerichtsurteil könne er den
hinrichtungen nicht zustimmen doch
langhäuser widerstand bleibt vergeblich
denn der befehl kommt von höchster
stelle direkt aus dem führer zug die
zivilisten werden noch am selben tag
erschossen
wir müssen leider davon ausgehen dass
ein solches zögern wie bei langhäuser
und nochmal rück vergewissern
der versuch die maschinerie nochmal
aufzuhalten dass das die ausnahme
gewesen sind davon davon gibt es nicht
viele major langhäuser hat eine
eigenschaft bewiesen die im polenfeldzug
1939 selten ist zivilcourage
zivilcourage als sogar zu zeigen
bedeutet ja im prinzip zu sagen ich bin
zwar jetzt hier in uniform aber die
uniform rechtfertigt keine gräueltaten
ich bin immer noch als zivilist als
einzelner verantwortlich für das was ich
tue was wir für zivilcourage erhalten
auch brauchen ist das was psychologen
als effizienz erwartung bezeichnen also
die erwartung ich kann hier auch etwas
gutes bewirken
nach dem krieg berichten polnische
augenzeugen über die wenigen fälle
deutscher menschlichkeit und über die
vielen grauzonen
so besitzen am sechsten september 1939
ss einheiten einer panzerdivision ein
polnisches dorf die soldaten treiben die
jüdische bevölkerung zusammen und
sperren sie die synagoge
was geschieht hier jüdischer
heckenschützen herr hauptmann wie
räuchern sie jetzt aus
[Musik]
das ist so grausam dass sie raus
der offizier kritisiert an diesem tag
die art der tötung nicht den mordplan
selbst zurück bleiben in der synagoge
jene jüdischen polen welche die ss
bereits erschossen hatte doch auch am
schicksal der überlebenden juden ändert
der offizier nichts
letztendlich stellt sich natürlich schon
die frage was hat er denn gedacht
passiert mit den juden wenn man die
daraus lässt hätte er gleichen probleme
gehabt wenn man die auf einer lkw
geladen hätte und mit ihnen weg gefahren
wäre und das war ja nun tatsächlich ein
kennzeichen sehr vieler deutscher in
diesen zeiten so lange man es nicht
selbst gesehen hat so lange man es nicht
so genau wusste war man im prinzip
verein damit also man hat beobachtet
dass die jüdischen nachbarn plötzlich
nicht mehr da sind und hat sich mit der
vagen erklärung die werden umgesiedelt
dann auch gerne zufrieden gegeben
[Musik]
züge von menschlichkeit zeigen nur jene
soldaten die in der polnischen
bevölkerung keine untermenschen sie herr
soldat
ich habe erfahren sie fahren morgen nach
krakau
meine eltern leben dort und wir sind
ganz allein
können sie uns helfen
ich habe auch drei kinder ich habe
diesen krieg wirklich nicht gewollt
gerne nehme ich euch mit fahre aber
schon sehr früh ab
es sind nur wenige szenen der
menschlichkeit wie diesel überliefert
doch es gibt sie
wenn ein mensch selbst eine tochter hat
dann bewegt es sich schon wenn er einem
vater und einer mutter begegnet die eine
tochter im ähnlichen alter haben
das ist eine selbstverständliche
psychische reaktion
dann kommt der schutz instinkt zum
vorschein der jedem menschen eigen ist
bei einem mister stärker bei dem anderen
schwächer aber jeder mensch hat diesen
and still
es gibt die erinnerungen meiner mutter
in denen sie erzählt wie ein deutscher
offizier der bei uns einquartiert war
eine gruppe polnischer jugendlicher
unter einem tisch versteckt hat über dem
eine lange decke lag
[Musik]
es war ein hochrangiger offizier